et le président wolo Dimir Zelenski le
président ukrainien vient d'arriver au
sommet de la Ligue arabe il poursuit sa
tournée diplomatique comme l'explique
Douglas Herbert notre envoyé spécial à
jedar
une visite complètement inattendue
de trouble-fêtes
zellens qui va vraiment s'aimer la
pagaille dans un sommet qui était censé
être au même au moins au début le sommet
de la réintégration de Bachar Assad au
sein de cette ligue de 29 nations arabes
c'est pas c'est un secret des
polichinelle que parmi les nations
membres de cette ligue il y en a
beaucoup d'alliés avec la Russie la
Russie l’ennemi juré maintenant bien sûr
de la l'Ukraine le pays qui mène une
guerre brutale contre du crâne c'est à
la veille bien sûr d'une grande
offensive du l'Ukraine c'est en train
d'être préparé à ce moment même par
zelanski et il a besoin bien sûr
d'élargir son camp de contact et il a
besoin de l'élargir bien au-delà du camp
occidental c'est également une façon
pour l'autre saoudien c'est-à-dire MBS
Mohamed Ben Salman de montrer aux
États-Unis jusqu'à quel point c'est un
poids lourd diplomatique dans la région
parce que en même temps que c'est les
Saoudiens qui dès avril dernier appelé
en faveur de la réintégration de
bachar-assad c'est également les
Saoudiens qui ont fini par apparemment
invités
en inviter à ce sommet alors ces deux
invités Bachar Assad la consécration et
zelanski diammatralement opposé au même
sommet au même jour ça devient très
intéressant